joe wicks and rosie good morning
good morning what's going on
so today i have um i my name's goopy
today on doctor's orders strict orders i
was in hospital this weekend with an
infection
in my hand i've been on morphine and
coding and he said look you cannot
exercise on money so i
text my wife on saturday night and said
rosie i'm in bits i don't think i can do
it
what do you say i i'm not taking the
class but i'm going to demonstrate the
exercises because i want him to rest and
let his hand get better so
she's my teaching assistant oh fantastic
and show me what the board is behind you
before we see some
some exercises so we've got teaching
assistant miss rosie wicks we're doing a
quiz which is um
mrs rogers we've got married this is
rosie whits
and the quiz is a history quiz we've
gotta spot the differences we've got
five different things around there
there's the evidence there's our wedding
photo
so we definitely should get married last
year i didn't forget it um
and we're doing a four week fitness
challenge but basically i spent the
weekend in hospital in nhs hospital in
kingston where both of our babies were
born
who you know amazingly looked after our
kids they came out
and you know i was in that hospital and
i was treated by someone from
ireland scotland iran um philippines sri
lanka
india and i thought what a wonderful
thing you can walk into any hospital in
the uk
you know the richest man or the poorest
man in town and they'll take care and
they love you and they look after you
and
for me that's such an important thing
and i feel so grateful and so i'm going
to dedicate this work out to the nhs and
also announce that we've raised
yes how'd you bring 10 200 grand so far
200 000 for the nhs charities together
fund that is
amazing rosie do you ever get a word in
edgeways
sorry no listen i'm happy for him to
keep talking i just want to do the
exercises
too much your turn i'm not used to this
he does this all day every day so tell
us how this is going to work today then
because you know we normally
see joe in the exercise gear he's got
his suit on and everything
that's because he's dressed today as the
teacher so i'm the assistant he did
actually do a whole pe with joe in a
suit once because he likes to
dress up but yeah and rosie on friday on
friday i was in so much pain i was like
all night thursday this infection
started coming and i was like i'm in
bits
i got up and done the workout as soon as
it was over it was throbbing went to the
hospital and i just thought
there's no way i can do the work and
even if i move it slightly i mean look
it's i'm not going to be
there too but it's an open wound the new
infections coming out but my beautiful
wife is going to demonstrate all the
exercises
um and she's had a baby four months ago
so she's amazing that she's
stepped up and done this and i said to
her you know in sickness and in health
this is me in sickness and
to her credit you know i love it a bit
she said i'll do it i didn't even bat an
island
and for that i'm you know really proud
of her look at that figure for a baby
four months ago you're killing me rosie
uh talk to me through what uh sort of
exercises we might see today
so we've got a little list are we gonna
be doing sort of jogging on the spot
will you let him get a word in edgeways
he makes up the workout like right
before we do it so he's just been making
me do
not making me having me like test out
the exercise and i'm so out of breath
already from doing like
one of each of the different exercises
so i think i'm gonna find this tough so
if anyone else is finding it tough i'm
gonna be there with you finding it tough
too we did get a break though we do 10
minutes then we get a little break in
between so it's ten minutes
two minute rest but we'd love you to
tune in because the more people that
tune in
the more money we raise through youtube
revenue and that money goes to the nhs
charities together fund like i said it's
at 200 grand because we've sold
loads of t-shirts we've done loads of
millions 50 million views
to the more people that come together
the more money we can raise for the
wonderful
that's nhs amazing both of you very well
done
just remind us joe take us back why you
came up with this idea in the first
place because
you are a frustrated pe teacher aren't
you
yeah i am i am i always was destined to
be a pediatric is what i went to
university for and
i've been doing all my uk school tours
i've been really passionate about this
for the past four years visiting schools
and i was supposed to be
on a uk tour and when the schools closed
down i was laying in bed i was like
there's no way
i can stop this mission i need to do
something so i had the idea of pee with
joe
a live workout every day monday to
friday and i had no idea it's been gone
for so long but
i've been doing it for six weeks this is
my seventh week i love it we've had 50
million people take part around the
world
and i'm super proud that now today i'm
doing with my wife
mr mrs rosie whis and hopefully more
even more people tune in today and
cheer us on and mrs wicks um what
involvement have you had up and
till now have you just been supervising
yeah well normally if if because we've
got a one and a half year old so
if she's running around i'm like
sleeping in the background trying to
make sure she doesn't touch any of the
computer she's getting quieter
yeah sometimes she likes to run in here
and take part um
or sometimes we do it downstairs we put
it on the tv and we try and join in but
i've got a little note i need to reach
as well this is from my mum um
because you know every time you miss p
you gotta have an opening tip for your
mum right
um dear teacher joe is unable to do pe
today because he forgot to i forgot to
watch his pe kit
he was also bitten by a dragon on friday
and had to spend the weekend in hospital
that's a true story indie was dressed as
a zombie she bit me on
friday ps he's matched homer got eaten
by a crocodile so
i'm excused by the doctor's orders and
my mother but rosie will be
demonstrating all the exercises and i
think it's going to be a fantastic work
i'm really excited for you darling i
actually am really excited yeah
yeah and a great thought before we maybe
we can see one or two exercises but but
just before we do that joe when do you
expect to be back in harness
well i'm hoping i can be back i mean
they told me like 10 days
two weeks should be doing anything but
there's no way they're going to hold me
down so um
i'm sure i'll be doing it probably
wednesday do you mind doing it tomorrow
today and tomorrow yeah and then you're
relieved so rose will be with me today
and tomorrow and then wednesday i'll be
back into it so let's demonstrate the
swatch here we've got a good squat
technique so
nice wide stance straight back sitting
down into the squat
and standing up tall see if i can do the
lower body ones it's fine just anything
where i move the hand
or do any kind of press keep going
darling let's go oh
that's it perfect remember inhale the
way down exhale you come up
perfect he does train me normally so i
am quite used to this that's why it
doesn't feel too nerve-wracking
i was going to say rosie you obviously
do a lot of exercise do you have a
routine of your own that you could share
with us
what do you normally do are you are you
a runner what are you doing
i'm being told what to do though i like
to be told what to do rather than to
just have to come up with my own i do
love it i come downstairs sometimes and
she'll be in the living room with indeed
doing one on youtube work
and i just think but also i've now i
just leave a pair of dumbbells like by
the tv so every so often because it's
obviously hard with two babies
i'll just pick them up and do a few
squats when i can rather than trying to
fit in the whole workout
that's amazing you have no idea you two
just how much you've inspired the nation
over these last six weeks we can't thank
you
enough great work and you've raised 200
000 as well and still going
fantastic to see you